thank you so much for being on the
program it's our first time I think yes
yes I've been dying to do it for ages so
thank you no not at all things coming on
um let's crack on shall we and talk
about the immigration policy that was
been discussed today so you're
announcing plans to try and stop housing
migrants in hotels when do you expect to
be able to say that look no more people
are going to be in these hotels well
clearly what we need to do is get enough
accommodation so that's been what the
focus has been and I don't think hotels
were ever meant to be long term and
clearly at a cost of six million pounds
a day they're definitely not meant to be
long term I mean that's taxpayers money
so but we have been trying to you know
work on getting more accommodation so I
think what we're trying to do now is get
ahead of the plans so we've got four
major sites and then we'll look at also
other options as well so no doubt then
really that you can you can give us
they'll be working on dates I can't give
you a date but they'll be working on you
know when they're going to try and get
enough you know accommodation we know
that the the we need enough
accommodation and you know that's what I
know my colleague Robert jamrick's been
working on is it really suitable to
families children even in disused
military sites you're comfortable with
that
obviously we need to make sure that they
are you know they're decent they're
clean
um you know and they're they're a decent
accommodation but I think is you know
it's it's a basic offer but it is an
offer that I think is is you know is is
decent enough as it were what does
decent enough mean well it's got you
know with the facilities that you need
it's clean you know it's uh it's it's
maybe not luxurious but it's certainly
um you know safe and decent and clean
are you expecting legal challenges on
this
um I don't know to be honest
um I mean we have lots of legal
challenges in this space but um and
that's part of you know part of the
problem has been delaying you know some
aspects of the longer term Solutions as
well which is uh there are the Rwanda
solution for a lot of things that are
coming going there yeah well those are
coming here illegally obviously that is
the plan no I mean we did win the case
in the in the in the court you know the
high court but of course it's now on
appeal so we still need to go through
those legal challenges but there have
been a number of legal challenges which
have held us up yes okay uh now I just
want to talk to you about strikes
because this is what so many of our
viewers are going to be really impacted
by whether they've got children at
school of course seeing the school
closures that we've seen due to strike
action now you've offered teachers what
you're describing as a final offer pay
deal what what exactly is it well it's
what I've offered it's a fair and
reasonable offer is how I've described
it so what we're asked to do is we ask
the teachers to pause their strikes and
the teachers union there's only one
teachers union actually the Neu that are
on strike and we ask them to pause their
strikes actually the same time as the
nurses and come in and have those talks
about you know what we could offer and
what we did is we opened up again the
2223 pay after after we'd agreed you
know the independent pay review body
um you know their recommendations
um they didn't accept that straight away
so they had five more days of strikes
which are really disappointing and they
are disruptive to children and they are
disrupted to parents as well and you
know we're very concerned about that
because said about kids that need to
catch up can say and about exam cohort
success what just be Crystal Clear what
is the offer on the table the offer is
so we've reopened 2223 it's a thousand
pounds for every school teacher and
school leader
um so that is a one-off payment it's
worth a different percentage depending
on where you are but it's 1 000 pounds
for all and then for the 23 24 pay which
we would normally go to an independent
payment view body we've offered 4.5 and
the inflation period at that time
obviously the obr have done a forecast
as part of the budget so that goes from
September 23 to to 24. it's not as much
inflation as less than two percent in
that period it's not as much as I got in
Scotland as it they've been offered a
seven percent rise between April 2022
and March 2023 five percent between
April and December 2023 and then a 2
increase why are teachers in Scotland
worth well we've said all along that we
are not trying to you know match the
Scottish or what we have very different
pay structures and they're very
different roles as well so we you know
we we have our own responsibilities and
clearly here starts with different roles
I mean like most teachers would think
like you're in schools you you deserve
it yeah but the pay structures are
actually quite complex you know it's not
just everybody talks about these
headline figures there's actually a lot
of progression pay so actually this is
actually what you're 44 more um for more
um established teachers is actually
lower than those of new starters as well
isn't it so no I mean it depends on
where you are there's progression pay as
well it is actually much more complex
with with the you know it's the headline
figures are what you talk about but the
offer we've made is one thousand pounds
lump sum and 4.5 when
um average earnings are predicted to be
2.3 and inflation is predicted to be
below two so I think that's a fair and
reasonable offer I mean obviously it's
the UK government we have the
responsibility for the economy we've got
the responsibility of halving inflation
we've got the responsibility of making
sure we get that fair balance between
the taxpayer who obviously pays for this
and you know the public sector workers
so we we alone have that balance to do I
want to you mentioned that average pay
and I do think it's important to compare
what teachers are seeing as opposed to
other professions as well because what
some teachers unions would argue is that
look they've had a long time of squeezed
pain I think we can just have a look
quickly now this is the office for
National statistics real-time pay Rises
is 2011. you can see train drivers and
then the private sector the public
sector nurses and all the way down at
the bottom is Teachers you can see why
they'll be feeling a little bit hard
done by if you looked at that going back
to 20 2012. yeah so the point that they
make is they've been a couple of years
over this period where teachers didn't
get a pay rise so I think there was a
couple of years in you know the
beginning when obviously there was no
money left as it were as the note said
and then there was I think a right a a
period in the pandemic as well when
obviously we decided to put public
resources to the fellow scheme this is
comparing it to other professions right
train drivers nurses things in the
public sector these are all facing the
same cost pressures right yeah but
people are teachers people have
different they're all different on
different salaries and they all have
different terms and conditions and they
all have different progression pay as
well so they're all very different so
they are quite difficult to compare but
the point they're making is there was a
few years where they didn't get pay rise
and if you add up real term Rises then
they want to to make up for that but
that's why we've said I mean this year
we've governed an extra thousand pounds
and that's why if you look at the 4.5
that we've offered for next year
inflation during that period uh
September to September is expected to be
way below two percent well I mean that
will start placing above inflation
inflation last month actually at strip
what many people well we're obviously
wanting a few price expect inflation
which you know is a lot of what people
we know we've had a spike in population
salaries honors we know start a spike in
inflation we know the reasons why we
know all the individual drivers so do
the obr and the obr obviously have made
their forecast and that's all we can
take to be honest that's you know
they're the forecasts that we're using
to try and clear you know we're
predicting into the future right this is
a pay rise for the future and that's
what the independent pay review body
predicting to do predicting to the
Future as well you've got to teach a
recruitment crisis Brewing right if you
look at the national Foundation of
educational research the target for
Teacher recruitment for next year is 100
there's only going to be 79 of the
primary school teachers needed and 58 of
the secondary school teachers sounds
like a crisis waiting to happen so what
we did um in Recruitment and it is
obviously vital that you recruit the
best you're worried about this surely
your education secretary you must be
looking at these figures and taking step
back thinking oh my goodness absolutely
so that's why we put in place bursaries
so actually it's not all equal across
all subjects and it's not equal we have
had post pandemic yeah there's if you
look at Classics and physical education
that's okay but actually if you look at
like Primary School teachers if you look
at Primary School usually is okay this
is the first time because we've got
we've got this dislocated labor impact
post the pandemic so there are every
single everything from heavy Goods
drivers to nurses pretty much every to
restaurants everything there is a a
shortage of Wages that's why the whole
bunch of salary only one of these
professions teaches the children but
what all of those that's why the whole
budget was really aimed at getting more
people back into work and to to making
sure that we've got the people to grow
however you're right we need to recruit
the best teachers we need to retain the
best teachers and I 100 committed to do
that so when we we put in place a
retention and recruitment strategy we
we've also said we will look to update
that as well because clearly you can't
have a first-class world-class education
system without fantastic teachers so 100
and I've done this many times you know
my long business career I've long long
lots of times had to face you know
Workforce shortages or skills challenges
and you have to put a plan in place the
plan in place includes bursaries it also
includes increasing graduate salaries as
well to make it competitive and so we
have um bursaries up to 29 000 pounds in
place for some of these subject areas so
we're not sat there ignoring this but
there is a pandemic impact as well
um I asked if people have questions for
you before the interview and a lot of
people were asking how can schools fund
a pay rise when you're not getting any
new money so Rob boys an assistant head
teacher how does she expect any school
to fund a pay rise for staff without
implementing redundancies schools are
operating with skeleton staff as it is
we can't recruit Megan Pacey who works
in early childhood education how can
schools many team budgets are in deficit
or near deficit and who rely on
fundraising to provide basic Learning
Materials like art resources and books
how can they pay for the desperately
needed seller increases on an unfended
basis this is absolutely a fair question
so when I first started the job which
was the end of October waiting for me
was a letter from all the unions
actually saying to fund the pay Rises
that the independent pay review body had
recommended 5.4 percent on average for
22.23 obviously we've now uh added a
thousand pounds to that they said we
need two billion pounds extra and to our
other inflationary pressures as well you
know energy costs Etc so the very first
thing I had to do within two weeks of
the job was to go to the chancellor for
the Autumn statement and get two billion
pounds extra for this year and for next
year now that is we've secured that it
will be going into schools budget
shortly so there is extra money coming
now that is for you know the pay Rises
that are agreed before already agreed
now on top of that what we've said is we
will fully fund the one thousand pounds
because that's uh not going to be within
those budgets because of where the the
other things that budget School budgets
are looking at so in particular energy
costs we think that the school budgets
and the ifs actually have confirmed this
as well can probably fund up to about
four percent of next year's pay rise but
that leaves half a percent Delta so in
total if I take those two together that
would be 620 million pounds extra that I
would have to find new money for schools
so and we've said that we've committed
to that I mean clearly schools we don't
expect them to to give head teachers the
problem of a thousand pounds for
everybody but not knowing how to fund it
so we will be funding that and I think
it's really important because if I look
at Twitter which I try not to but I
sometimes have to but if you look at
Twitter if you look at other things I
don't think and listen to those
questions most people seem to have
missed the two billion pounds that was
fully funded at the last time the fact
that people haven't missed people
haven't missed the the money that was
given in the Autumn statement this is
additional cost pressures on schools
that they have to try and find in
addition to the money that was given
before and let's not forget of course it
hasn't actually gone yet schools I've
had it's been announced a decade it's
been announced they haven't had it in
their budget they've had a decade of
what many would describe as underfunding
I just wondering can I just I'd like to
pick you up on that point because if you
listen to the ifs they've now said with
the additional let's have a look at the
additional Manchester yeah because the
additional graphic from the ifs so this
is the school funding percentage of
change per pupil since uh you can see
the world line 2010 when the
conservatives first of power and you can
see the private schools line in blue and
the state's calls line in red and I
think it stops a year early so if you go
up to where we would be now all the
money we've announced my point which is
we're talking about the decade of what
many people will describe as
underfunding well if you if you look at
this line I think it is really an
important line to look at there was one
bump a year which is 2010. so that year
just as they were leaving office there
was a huge rise in the budget it wasn't
there all the way through it was this
huge rise and then of course we they
left us with no money but if you take
this now to where we are today we are
now back 58.8 billion pounds which is
the highest we've ever funded schools in
history so it is important to say that
because as okay as of this next year
that's that extra 2 billion when it's
added to the budget so that's where it
will be do you and it is you know you
you've got answers to all the questions
you've got lots of
um you know stats to throw you're saying
that these these can't be compared this
is the equivalent over do you get how
worried parents are right now you know
the teachers are striking kids are not
in school many of them who've missed
time from Junior pandemic they're
looking at school funding and they're
worried do you get they shouldn't worry
about the school funding because the
money with extra money even the teachers
who parents are being asked to like fund
things like art supplies like 58.8
billion pounds is a lot of money we
spend in our schools so they shouldn't
be worried about that okay and and the
extra money is coming for the budget but
the most important thing is I want
teachers to know because they'll be
having to ballot on this now they'll be
having to vote the 1 000 pounds and the
4.5 percent you know there will be extra
funding to make sure that schools can
afford that and if we don't have this
agreement which you know we've done our
best we've I mean I spent all less a
couple of weekends ago with them we've
you know gone till early hours Etc to
try and thrash out as much as we can
then what we will do is we'll go to the
independent pay review process they will
come up with something for 23.24 but
they won't come up with anything for 20
20 23 so it is important that they know
that because it is funded and I do want
them to have it we are out of time there
are so much stuff that I want to talk to
you about not least you're in background
you went to a comprehensive school
started apprenticeship at 16 and so
hopefully get and I really care about
this Sofia and the reason I know all the
facts and figures is because I want to
be fair I don't want you know I want to
know if it's actually are we funded
schools enough are kids going to get
best education and I think are we paying
teachers enough to make sure that we get
enough teachers and the answer to those
questions because people will have very
different views on but thank you very
much thank you thank you Sophie